it's a pleasure sitting across from you
on stage after interning at the Gates
Foundation this past summer so I want to
spend some time today talking a little
bit about the values and decisions that
have really shaped where you are today
as well as here a little bit of your
thoughts around where you are going as
well as where the Gates Foundation is
going that's good I'm glad to be here
so let's start off by talking about two
of the really big pillars that have been
constant in your career health care and
education and in fact your father was a
pharmacist and your mother was a teacher
so I'm interested to hear a little bit
about how what kinds of lessons they
taught you and how have those lessons
really shaped the way you thought about
your career as you all just heard I grew
up in Reno Nevada biggest little city in
the world and although I'm a California
native so now that I'm in Seattle by the
way I'm getting all sorts of grief about
Kaepernick a lot of trash talk up there
but but I I feel like today and my
entire career has been so heavily shaped
by how I was raised I'm one of seven
kids and number two of seven and from a
very early age there was there were a
couple things that that I got from my
parents that stay with me today one is
just a fierce love of reading and
learning from my mom who was an English
teacher and and a sense of the privilege
it is to be involved in health from my
dad who's a pharmacist and being able to
work in my dad's drugstore when I was
young and seeing how my dad was so
focused on people who were suffering or
sick and trying to make them better made
a big impact on my wish to see if I
could do something to contribute in
medicine and you've made a lot of really
unorthodox decisions in your career
first going
to Uganda in the late 1980s to study
hiv/aids at a time where not very much
was known about the disease and later
leaving the number one pharmaceutical
company to go to what was a relatively
new and struggling biotech company
Genentech not a lot of people would take
those kinds of risks so tell me a little
bit about what you were looking for at
those times
how were you weighing the benefits
versus the cost of those decisions yeah
I think it's actually learned a lot of
lessons both about leadership and about
risk taking from both of those
opportunities so I had been at at UCSF
for seven years when the Rockefeller
Foundation came to UCSF and asked UCSF
to study heterosexual transmission of
HIV it's hard to remember now but at the
time in 1988 it was thought to be a
disease related to either being gay or
having a blood product and
there was a myth then that in fact there
was this secret homosexuality going on
in Africa and that must have been why
that people were too embarrassed to
confess that they were gay but that that
heterosexual transmission of HIV was
probably a myth and so when Rockefeller
came to UCSF UCSF asked me and my then
husband who's an infectious disease
doctor to move to Kampala to work in
Uganda and and I have a very distinctive
memory of one of my dear colleagues Bob
Cohen telling me that I would ruin my
career by moving to Uganda it was really
good advice and in fact it actually it
was good advice because he was right for
two years I didn't publish I didn't lose
or interact or do things you do to
become a tenure-track faculty member and
when we came back from Uganda which was
a completely life-changing experience in
every way and there were two things that
stayed with me one is that my academic
career was a
and I needed to leave and figure out how
to pay the rent and and make a living
and to that I would never be the same
and that my own expectations of myself
all the privilege I had had my whole
life and what I expected from myself as
a leader and as somebody who who was so
fortunate to have education and clean
water and great parents and a great
family and a wonderful husband that I
needed to give back and I needed to do
something I will tell you when I became
Chancellor at UCSF I called up Bob and I
said hey Bob I made it back it's like it
worked out all right I just skipped that
all associate professor thing so that
was that was a huge risk especially to
my burgeoning academic career but a
really good risk so that later when I
was at bristol-myers Squibb and I was
working on tax all which was their
number one cancer drug and a terrific
new advance in chemotherapy I visited
Genentech and that was in in 95 and art
Levinson was the head of R&D and art
talked to me about Genentech swish to be
a cancer company but Genentech had no
marketed products that were cancer drugs
but they had terrific science an
incredible vision that art had that they
would lead in cancer and that genetic
would transform how people were treated
who had cancer and I was so deeply
inspired by that vision that I thought
it will you know nothing may come of
this but I want to be part of that and
having had the experience of taking a
risk before and knowing that the
consequences of not taking that risk and
not seeing what might be possible wasn't
acceptable to me and and so that that
career risk-taking seemed seemed totally
reasonable which is probably why I'm not
at UCSF anymore I mean that the Gates
Foundation
and you mentioned art Levinson who hired
you really helps to catapult your career
as an executive at Genentech art has
said that when you first got there you
were a little bit soft you needed to
learn how to make tough decisions do you
agree with that assessment and if so how
did you develop that ability it depends
on your definition of soft so our art
was my boss for most of the 14 years I
was at Genentech and we remain really
close friends and colleagues which i
think is one of those special things
that I hope that all of you and your
careers get to experience is a
combination of a boss who is so
inspiring and so driven and passionate
about having a successful company and
making a difference for patients and
sometimes so deeply annoying and and
there were two things annoying about art
for me that I grew to be really fond of
one was him pushing me that I should be
tough on on everything that that as
driven as I am and as I was it was okay
to be demanding of others in service of
what we were trying to accomplish that I
shouldn't be embarrassed about that or
think that people would think I mean or
too tough and so I do think there was
sort of a toughness factor and not being
afraid of asking people to overachieve
in service of what we were trying to do
that I learned from art but the other
thing in a really special thing that I
push myself to think about all the time
is I got from art that he really felt
like I consistently underestimated
myself and in in the best of ways he
would demonstrate to me that he was
going to keep raising the bar for what
he wanted for me or what he expected
from me and yet he was completely
confident I was up to it even when I
wasn't and as a leader and as somebody
who meant
manages other people that sense that it
isn't being nice to them to
underestimate them or be easy on them
but to say I bet you're capable of more
and and yeah I'm I'm gonna ask you hard
things but you're up to it that was a
really special thing to have a boss like
that I'm very grateful for that
what is what do you think it's like to
work for you at this point so art was a
tremendous influence but yeah I mean I'm
interested to know why thank you how
would you how do you think the people
who work for you describe your
leadership gosh can I make up something
really great well I'll tell you what I
hope they would they would feel when I
get excited about things I'm all-in you
know and and I'm I've been so incredibly
lucky to be involved with things from
trying to change the way cancers treated
to creating a great university to
literally changing the world through our
work at the foundation I hope that what
people who I work with would say about
me is I'm fierce and demanding and and
sincere and my wish that we make a big
difference and what I want it to be like
when I'm leading is both fun and
exhausting because I honestly think it's
you don't get great things without
trying hard and you know this rooms
filled with people who are overachievers
I know that about you and so many
overachievers feel like oh my god you
know I need more work/life balance or I
need to be easier on myself or I need to
get more sleep but there's something
really special about being fierce when
you're doing something important or you
want to create something special and and
I hope that that when I met my best I'm
fierce I know you've said before carpe
diem is something that you really
believe in so it's interesting to hear
how that plays out in your leadership
philosophy
you see I think one of the interesting
things about your career is that you've
spent time both on the commercial sector
side and in the not-for-profit education
as well as now the philanthropic sector
what do you think the lessons are that
you took from your time on the corporate
side to UCSF when you went there as
Chancellor huge recession budget cuts
across the state what were the biggest
things that you were thinking about and
how did you take your perspective your
very unique perspective and use it to
make change well I I think the the the
experience I had had in the corporate
sector was helpful to me and moving to
UCSF and now to the foundation in a
couple of ways one is and it's something
I like a lot about the for-profit
publicly traded company world there's a
certain orderliness and set of
expectations that come regularly once a
quarter you have to tell the whole world
how you're doing and you have to do so
with metrics that are widely understood
earnings per share the sales if you're
in product development number of
approvals product launches do people
like your products are they using them
and I think particularly when you're in
science and when you're in the R&D world
it can be easy to continue to push the
finish line forward and and to put off
accountability and so I think first and
foremost the commercial world resonated
for me in a very high accountability
metrics oriented way and so bringing
that model of high accountability and
using metrics to the academic world was
important to me and serve me well the
other aspect of the private world that
that I brought to UCSF and already was
at UCSF but I probably expanded is the
wish to have effective public-private
partnerships but to be realistic about
and I'll give you an example I think one
of the most efficient ways for people to
lead is to be really clear about what
you're asking of people and what the
outcomes are too often in academia we
would be approaching private companies
and somehow out of fear of rejection I
think we would be unclear we would be
asking for charity like could you write
us a check because you care about UCSF
and we're going through a tough time but
we would pretend it's a business deal
and I would often talk to faculty
members about these these public/private
partnerships and push ourselves first
but then the companies as well is this
part of your business plan are we part
of your business plan because that's
called a deal what do you need what do
we need what money exchanges hands what
are the expectations or do you have a
charitable part of what you're doing
that you'd like to give us a check and
we'll thank you and and be grateful
those are really different things and
the consequences of misunderstanding the
difference between a deal and charity
are high and so partly because I had
come from the private sector
understanding what a head of R&D are a
head of a company is looking for for
their company and what UCSF needed and
was looking for for us as a public
institution hopefully there'd be some
marriage but if there wasn't it was
better not to even start one of the more
controversial proposals that you had at
UCSF was potentially separating some of
the operations and finances of the UCSF
campus from the UC system that didn't
end up coming to fruition and I'm
curious to know is there anything that
you learned from putting that proposal
out there and having it in some
sentences fail in the way that you
didn't intend what could you have done
differently if anything I think that
that I learn a lot of lessons from that
one is I think it's in service of the
university being a great institution I
I'll tell you what I feel good about I
feel good about pushing pushing really
hard that anything I could do to serve
the governance of UCSF in a positive way
and leverage all the assets the e CSF
had and has in service of being the best
institution we could possibly be for
California and for the world is
something I was very motivated by and
driven by in my quest to increase the
independence of EC SF on the governance
front where I think I probably
underestimated is the passion with which
the Regents look at the whole of the ten
universities of California as as one and
although I thought it was pretty low
risk for them to take a graduate student
only life sciences only am i selling you
as an experiment one time only low
consequence I think I underestimated two
things one is the history and the
passion with which people care about the
unified UC system and the other thing is
how quickly my colleagues especially at
Berkeley wanted to go with me and so me
positioning this is a one-time
experiment only UCSF as Berkeley was
kind of latching on and in coming along
it kind of made it seem like a sham that
this was a one-time small experiment and
and so I learned a lot from that and I
also learned about the importance of not
going so fast that you kind of hit a
wall but you know at the Gates
Foundation we have this saying that
we're impatient optimists my impatience
may have gotten the best of me
because I wanted it now and and my
optimism probably got the best of me too
in thinking that people would go along
on the other hand my successor
Chancellor Hawgood continues to reap the
benefits of the Regents understanding
better the business model of ICI SF
how UCSF operates how an academic
Medical Center receives funds and the
importance of being nimble in today's
world of healthcare and so I hope that
the Institute
and and Chancellor Hogg would continue
to reap the benefits of Leaning out
maybe a little ahead of my skis as a
biotech executive really responsible for
the R&D side of things you really have
to become very comfortable with the risk
of failure very early on and think about
the portfolio and how you're going to
manage that appropriately how do you as
a leader think about treating failure
and taking risks and how do you sort of
let that viewpoint trickle down within
your organization the the risk of
failure for me is something that is a
part of being an innovator I don't think
you can do excellent innovation without
failing and failing serially sometimes
but but I think that there's there's a
couple of ways that I thought about that
and I continue to think about that you
think it's a key part of leadership to
have an environment that accepts failure
and welcomes failure and encourages
people to take risk but I mentioned
before how how accountability is really
important to me and so one of the things
I think in any venture when you have a
portfolio of projects and I had a
portfolio of projects at Genentech and I
have a portfolio of projects at the
foundation that we oversee no
institution can fail serially and
succeed and so what what I would always
ask of people and and especially in the
clinical trials world so that pertains
to the things we're doing in global
health but but even more broadly our job
as innovators is to seek truth and if
you're making a new product for human
beings truth might be that that product
is neither safe nor effective what the
company needed from us and actually what
the world needs from us now is clear
answers that we believe sometimes the
answer is no and so the job of people
who are innovators is to quickly and
efficiently get a clear answer that we
believe and so I tried to set an
environment where I rewarded
clear efficient answers and I
particularly awarded in the face of
human health if the answer is this is
unsafe this isn't good for patients or
there's a better drug that somebody else
has and it's not going to be us if you
reward and celebrate the people who get
to that answer good things happen if you
if you expect the answer is always yes
or that people have projects that always
succeed you start playing small ball you
have small incremental progress if any
progress at all and if people find an
answer that's a no they don't want to
tell you that and so part of the most
important part of leading an innovative
environment for me is enabling people to
seek the truth and tell you the truth I
know you've had a chance to think a lot
about seeking truth and how to create
that kind of culture within an
organization at the Gates Foundation
which you joined last May so it's been
not quite a year yet but a lot has
happened since then and I'm curious and
now that you've had some time under your
belt what do you want your personal
legacy at the Gates Foundation to be as
it heads into its you know upcoming 15th
year I believe it's in its 15th year
right now so what do you want your
legacy to be there well it there's a few
things that I care about most some of
them are short-term but you're asking
about legacy it's not uncommon for
people to remind me that I am the CEO of
the largest foundation in the world and
that's interesting big is good we have
scale we can make important things
happen so in the in the simplest of ways
I'd rather be known as the best
foundation in the world and the
foundation that that made a really big
difference that made important things
happen
and so what that means for me it kind of
breaks down into if I want us
move from biggest to really that's
that's the foundation that if I have
wealth makes me want to be a
philanthropist if I can do a job makes
me want to work in the not-for-profit
sector maneuv aute a certain way it's to
vote for the kind of policies that
enable the work the foundation does all
of that means that the work we do at the
foundation needs to take our investments
which in the bigger world although we're
the biggest foundation are small versus
government and and other sectors
especially the private sector that that
our work enables that transformation we
want to have happen and that that that's
visible and meaningful and that we
attract great talent because the culture
of the foundation means that you know
I'm on the Procter & Gamble board and
it's really interesting to me that
people like Scott Cooke and Meg Whitman
still talk about that early on their
first job was at Procter & Gamble I want
people to say you know during my career
I was at the Gates Foundation every bit
as much as meg says you know I was a
product manager at P&G because that
means that's a special life-changing
experience for that person so I want to
lead the organization that is that
organization what do you think are gonna
be the biggest challenges for you to get
to that goal which having worked at the
Gates Foundation I love and definitely
adhere to what are those challenges
going to be and how are you mitigating
them through your leadership well I
think there's challenges on two fronts
one is we have audacious ambitions you
know if I start running off the list it
makes me feel a little sweaty you know
solve polio tackle malaria tuberculosis
HIV African sleeping sickness improve
life for smallholder farmers get 120
million more women on modern
contraception by 2020 oh and fix the US
educational system while we're at it
that too so I think on the impact front
because we're tackling some of the
world's hardest problems with metrics
we're really visibly pushing ourselves
to make a huge difference and so for me
being a great foundation starts with
impact and and that impact requires us
to be great collaborators work with
others towards these very important
audacious goals and so doing that
effectively means it starts with the
awareness we have of our place in the
world how can our capital serve as
leverage serve as a lubricant be
transformational what are the unique
things we can do as a foundation that
others won't do and on the culture side
it is hitting that sweet spot that I
mentioned before I always felt like my
best days at work have come just in the
perfect middle of feeling really
comfortable and free and like I can do
anything and totally terrified and being
frozen and and so somewhere at the Gates
Foundation I want people to feel like
and I can make anything happen and we we
have just incredibly talented people who
should feel that way and it's a
high-wire act to pull off what we're
trying to pull off so can we just hit
that middle you know where you're both
terrified and excited making a culture
for really talented people where it
feels just right exhilarated not
overwhelming excited and a little
terrified that kind of culture is
special and wonderful and takes enormous
energy every single day to live up to
that you're working with two of the most
engaged and smartest philanthropist that
there are in the world Bill and Melinda
I feel I have a responsibility to ask
what so many of the audience are
thinking what's it like to work with
them and in particular how have you had
to adjust your leadership style in order
to work effectively with this type of
partnership I work at a family business
or as other people in the foundation
world have told me your donors are alive
they're very alive I can tell you
happily minoo it's manat sure how to
answer your question I I learned a very
important leadership lesson in and we
talked about art Levinson and Minh of
the most important things I learned from
working with art who came from Rd to
being CEO he did not adjust his
personality to become the CEO he was as
goofy and as as nerdy as he was when he
was the head of research when he became
the CEO and so I think great leaders and
I know leaders I admire show up as
themselves every day and so when I
approached being the CEO with Bill and
Melinda I knew there were two
extraordinary special people and I said
I'm just gonna be myself and I'm gonna
be myself through the whole interview
process and if that's embarrassing to
them or if I'm too weird or you know
they don't like how I operate
then they'll figure it out during the
interview process and they won't be
surprised and so I had an interview with
Bill that was funny because people had
told me why when he gets mad you know
this is gonna be bad
so I thought well maybe I should test
what it's like if he's mad so so I had
read something about a criticism about
the the Foundation's focus on polio
eradication you know there's a lot of
other problems in the world and we're
spending too much and so when I was
interviewing with Bill I said so what do
you think about all the criticism of the
polio efforts I thought well maybe
that'll get him you know because I
wanted to test what it would be like if
he was fired up and you know he did
react and then I realized there's a
really big difference between getting
him fired up and being mad and being mad
at me which that didn't really test that
well so happily
I haven't had that experience good but
but I would say I am so enjoying working
with Bill and Melinda they're very very
different from each other and very
complimentary and and what they have in
common is incredible almost impossible
to explain generosity and the the most
sincere wish that their generosity and
their foundation changes the world in
positive ways and that's real and
fundamental and the reason I'm there and
and Bill's impatience doggedness
brilliance and everything that bill is
and everything he's brought to the world
he's bringing to the work at the
foundation is is just magnificent you
know it's just a really special powerful
thing and Melinda's sense of social
justice her incredible caring for women
and girls
she's like the world's best most
enthusiastic mom and brings all that to
the job and so on any given day I get to
work with Bill and Melinda or bill or
Melinda and tap into all the power and
passion and intellect that both of them
bring to the job and we have to get
stuff done and and that's their
expectations the other thing I'm
learning which i think is just a really
important thing both in a family
business but in anything you do in life
where you have co-chairs they're not the
same they don't know was agree and so
one of the most important things I can
do is to point out where they're coming
at something from two different places
and it's part of my background in
science and technology I think truth
comes out of messiness and I think
that's an asset I bring to the
foundation that if bill am willing to
disagree or see things in different ways
because of their different perspectives
I want to make that visible I'm not
afraid of that in fact I embrace that
because my fundamental belief as a
leader is the more disparate voice
for me a big part of diversity and why I
like diversity is the more different
views that come from very different
places it really good outcomes will
happen we'll get a better answer or the
best answer from that so I'm trying to
tap into that part of me and that
affinity I have for differences to be a
good partner for the two of them I think
I one more question before we turn it
over to the audience for QA but you have
been able to balance that delicate
intersection between having a successful
career and also having a life of meaning
and that's a question I think a lot of
us in the audience are trying to wrestle
with right now is how do we have both of
those things what advice do you have to
share with us about how we can think
about our careers going forward well
it's one of the aspects of my life that
we haven't talked about that's the most
special to me is I'm a cancer doctor so
as a cancer doctor you interact with
people in a really special way and that
is often you have to tell people that
they're gonna die faster than you hope
and faster than they would wish for
themselves and I think in the in the
worst ways and the worst days that made
me feel like a failure like I just
couldn't fix things that I wanted to fix
and the best outcome of that for me was
what you talked about before my own
sense of carpe diem you know every day
is precious every week is a great week
that I get to have and so I just really
believe in having fun if I'm in the
middle of something hard if I'm working
if I'm not at work I want everything I
experience to be meaningful and special
and I've not always been great at
work-life balance but I'm really good at
having fun
I don't believe in suffering it just is
overrated and I often tell people and in
this in academia I can tell you guys
know dismissal of academia but this
thing of being the most pitiful
I told faculty members do not come in my
office and claim to be the most pitiful
there I'm not giving an award for that
you know I don't believe in it so for me
and everybody's different for me making
sure that I have fun that I get to enjoy
my colleagues at work I've spent a lot
of time at work I should enjoy my
colleagues I should find out what about
them is interesting that I can learn
from and I can enjoy I really like
sports I really enjoy being with my
husband I like my family and spend time
with my family but just deciding that
life's gonna be fun and that if there's
ever a week or a month where it's not
that it starts with me making sure it is
and I tell my colleagues at the Gates
Foundation because we're all into it and
we overdo we are serial / doers
it's self-managed nobody's gonna
understand as well as you do how much
sleep you need how much fun you need how
much exercise you need what you should
eat who you should surround yourself
with so manage yourself so that you can
be happy and I think if there's any one
thing that I've tried to do and I'm not
always successful in doing it it's to
manage myself
so that I enjoy life and I can show up
better if I do that and and that's been
really good self advice and I'm trying
to take it well thank you sue so we're
going to now turn things over to the
audience for Q&A we've got some mics
that are going to be passed around on
this first level if you could raise your
hand and keep your hand raised once you
get the mic please stand up and share
your name and affiliation before stating
your question we also have a hashtag
that you can use in order to tweet your
questions which we'll also be taking
that's a good option for those of you
who are in the balcony so that hashtag
is
hashtag GSB the FTT and we'll start with
a question over here fellow here and
find out the B course which is a group
of progressive companies around the
world we're big fans of your foundation
actually one of the foundation I'm
involved terrible foundation gave in a
wood Malinda foundation last year so but
I have a question we in Europe we see
your foundation as a kind of model of
what a u.s. foundation can be and
sometimes the question is you seem to be
very focused on health and health and
given the many of the challenges in the
world are systemic we just wonder
whether you've had discussion you have
discussion about this sort of dilemma
being too focused versus being more of a
generalist because actually there's also
a tradition of many US foundations thank
you thanks for the questions so the
foundation has has a focus on global
health global development that includes
agriculture financial services for the
poor some of the areas that that are
broader beyond health and in the u.s.
our primary focus is on US education the
foundation is always asking ourselves
about the scope of our work and where we
spend our time and energy and our funds
and we often have small projects that
are going on to assess whether we should
go into other areas and and more broad
one of the really positive aspects about
the focus on global health as an example
and I think why the Gates Foundation
originally went down that road is it's
really clear what the global burden of
disease is and one can make very crisp
decisions to use global burden of
disease as your metric for what you're
going to tackle there's a clarity of
that and a really clear purpose of doing
that so that we can have metrics both
for success and about what we tackle
when we look in some other areas we
always ask does the foundation have a
unique opportunity to contribute and
will we be able to measure and know if
our efforts are making a difference some
of the most important things were asked
about don't have those attributes that
are is easy to track or measure and yet
we continue to push ourselves
to ask that question they've a question
from Twitter
yep this is from first year MBA Daniel
burrows yes you say the Gates Foundation
is the biggest in the world but is it
big enough for its objectives
yes if so we're big enough to meet our
objectives if we think of our funds and
our resources which include the people's
time and energy at the foundation as
leverage and so it's not uncommon for
the foundation to be involved in an
effort the Global Alliance for vaccines
initiative is a good example that are
going to raise more than seven billion
dollars to bring vaccines to the world's
poorest people that involves a global
effort on global vaccinations on low
price accessible vaccines our efforts
are magnified by the leverage we get
when others come in so I think our
ambitions are not too large if we think
of our efforts as bringing others in and
the leverage you get from the
Foundation's investments hi my name is
Austin I had a question that kind of
piggybacking off the the response he
gave to the first question when you said
that there are a lot of issues that are
very difficult to measure outcomes for
and you're grappling with kind of how to
address that
I was curious as to your thoughts on do
you think that all beneficial or
positive outcomes that you're looking
for are eventually measurable and if not
how do you think about making change in
arenas where the outcome we're looking
for may never be fully and accurately
measured
that's the the direct answer your
question is no I think there are
important things we care about and
should care about that can't be measured
and that that brings a dilemma is one of
the things that I think is important to
recognize if you're in a not-for-profit
world is you you have to do better than
good intentions right good intentions
don't change the world by themselves so
I would be open to thinking about
something that can't have really clear
measurable outcomes like number of kids
vaccinated a number of people whose
lives were saved because they didn't get
measles for example those are really you
know as a physician I got that right
poverty poverty is measurable how much
money a family has poverty is a
measurable outcome if you start to focus
on poverty you have to look long-term
but there are some metrics that can be
associated with that social justice is
another thing that can start to get into
things so how do you know that you've
got social justice what would be most
important to me is that there's some way
to know your investments are moving some
needle so I think that there there are
maybe metrics that could be used that
can start to get at it and get a sense
for if you're changing outcomes that you
care about but but what would make me
unhappy is if we got into an area where
we really had no clue I just don't see
us doing that because the chance to
fritter away capital that could be used
on something where we can measure
outcomes would just be too high do we
have a question from this in speaking
with your predecessor the Gates
Foundation Jeff Raikes he mentioned of
wide variety of people who work in in
the foundation world some kind of
nonprofit types who are passionate about
social justice academics who want to
learn how to measure impact you know
with a lot of precision and private
sector types who kind of just want to
get things done and all three of those
types seem to be part of your career
back
so I guess my question is you know what
do you think you bring most to your job
leading the foundation and do you think
the balance is right do you think that
those disparate voices are leading to
truth or are you trying to steer the
foundation and in one of those
directions more than the others I think
it's great to have people involved in
the foundation world who come from a
variety of backgrounds and sectors I
think that's helpful and and healthy
what and I do think the mix generates
good outcomes what what I would focus on
is a couple of things that I think need
to be balanced what we've seen in the
philanthropic world is a lot of people
who've been successful in the private
sector come into the not-for-profit
world and there's been a little bit of a
culture clash and that's why I say this
this question of we no good when we see
it and good intentions have been sort of
traditional in the not-for-profit sector
or we're underfunded and understand
under a lot of things so don't expect
too much that it can feel like that in
the not-for-profit sector and so I think
bringing accountability resources talent
upping the ante is a really healthy
thing on the other hand I think it's a
valid criticism of a lot of newcomers to
philanthropy and I put myself on that
list that we can bring a certain naive
Tay and the naivete is bringing Western
solutions or a Western Way of thinking
or a very techie way of thinking to
problems that would be solved if you
actually sat down with the women in a
village and she could tell you why she
can't get water because it's something
simple that you tried to fix with a
complex solution and so I think that the
the the combination of bringing the
those resources that talent that passion
that accountability with with the
humility to understand that on the
ground in a different culture you really
don't know and everything's a
collaboration I think that combination
can generate something that can be very
positive that and the last thing I'll
say on that is the
as impatient as I am I do think the most
important great philanthropic outcomes
are measured in years not months thank
you I'll take a question from Twitter
but I also do want to say please make
sure to state your name and affiliation
when we call on you so this is from
Sharon she wants to know you you
mentioned at the beginning about ways to
motivate people and get them to provide
clear answers and take risks what kind
of behaviors don't you reward or do you
discourage
oh I'm trying I'm trying to give a short
answer some of my least favorite
probably my very least favorite is it
wasn't me that guy's the reason that
failed if not for him or his function or
his people we'd be in a different and
better place that's really high on my
list an answer not to give the other one
is is that we worked with a partner and
you know they saw it this way and that's
because they're stupid not they
disagreed with us or they come at it
from a different point of view or have a
different experience is to underestimate
either a partner or a different function
I love teamwork and and one of the great
things I was thrown into when I were two
bristol-myers Squibb is I got on a team
when I worked on taxol with
manufacturing and sales and regulatory
and and all these people who had no idea
what they did but I came really quickly
to understand none of the great stuff I
wanted to have happen would happen
without them and so the fact that I
didn't know what sales and marketing did
was me being ignorant not them having
value and and I think that's that's the
very important thing particularly for
technical people scientists physicians
is not to overestimate the fact that
because you know science or IT or
something that you that extends into
knowing everything so that would be on
the list too hi I'm Roz Naylor I direct
the center on food security in the
environment at Stanford and a professor
of environmental or system science I
really enjoyed the interview on both
your parts it's really wonderful I had a
question about coming into a large
organization where you have an
incredible global health program
agricultural development program
education program and at one level
you've got such talented people you want
to just give the best incentives and let
those divisions really take off yet at
the intersection of those different
divisions might be the most creative
solutions for example a number of the
global health issues may really be
dependent on much better nutrition or
the ending of malnutrition in those
areas
similarly the best advances in
agricultural development may be the
solving of some of the productivity
depleting disease issues how do you
motivate really good creativity and
productivity at the intersections when
when you really need some disciplinary
strength as well that is so hard to do I
can tell you that it's one of the
biggest challenges I'll give you two
ways that I've started to think about
this one is geography so we can take
advantage of the fact that we have
multiple programs going on in certain
geographies like northern India like
Ethiopia and we have what's called a
tech panel where we bring together in
the geography all of the various silos
in the foundation who are working on
different aspects of problems maybe
nutrition family planning vaccinations
and agriculture but all being done in
Ethiopia so bringing together those
folks so that they know what each other
are doing and coordinate through our
country offices and through that
geography can start to help us connect
those dots and look across the other
thing that I'm trying to do at the
foundation is have a very strong
executive leadership team it we can't
expect people in the trenches to
collaborate if the executive leadership
team isn't collaborating and I think in
the foundation in our foundation we've
expected the executive leadership team
to focus a lot on business process and
less on strategy I'm trying to turn that
on its head and have a much more
strategic focus on the executive
leadership team and look at those
intersections including the executive
leadership team showing up in pairs in
geographies and at the foundation so
that we can start connecting at our
level I'm an MBA one student and to
continue somewhat with a professor
nailers question how do you balance the
funding the funding of new technology
versus
the implementation of a specific
technology in a sector and then assuming
that that varies by by sector does this
have implications for how businesses
should consider opportunities
there's there's not a neat and tidy
answer to your question so so I will
tell you the the the way I start to
think about this is there are times when
delivery as you call it they're sort of
making the existing tools reach where
they need to reach makes good sense
often at scale that's the job of the
Ministry of Health for example or the
Ministry of Agriculture so so for me the
delivery aspect of what we do has to be
very clear often involve an innovation
or pilot or trying to do something that
then can be scaled because we're never
going to deliver on a global basis
that's that's for others to do that so
we have to be extremely purposeful with
our delivery methods and be thoughtful
about what that looks like and how we
make that real so that often involves
delivery innovation so really important
that delivery innovation is a part of
what we do on the technology side we
have an affinity and I have an affinity
for technology solutions but I look at
technology solutions through a really
clear lens and that is is will this
really change things so I was involved
in a discussion yesterday about cervical
cancer screening for cervical cancer and
preventing cervical cancer is really
hard at scale it involves women who are
35 to 50 a little older than typical
used the healthcare system in a low
resource country and you have to see
many many women before you can truly
prevent cancers so if we had a
diagnostic that looks at oncogenic
Pavlova papillomavirus if we had
something that really was was
transformative and saying all these
women don't need this expensive hard to
execute screening that would be a
transformative diagnostic that's the
kind of thing I want to fund so often
the best discussions I'm involved in
talk about delivery talk about a missing
technology and the likelihood that we
can provide something that transforms
that delivery that the ministry the
government others are providing because
everything's easier
to that that's where I think we're at
our finest given the limited time
remaining I want to conclude with a
question sue that is near and dear to
many of us in the audience what matters
most to you and why what matters most to
me is that the as a leader I can allow
for really talented people to do things
that improve people's chance at a happy
life the reason for me is and it kind of
gets back to how I was raised in the
environment I was in just I became a
physician because I really wanted and
want to think that you know to to the
Gates Foundation motto is all lives have
equal value so that everybody has a
chance to be healthy and happy and have
a the life they'd like for themselves
and their families and so thinking about
how you know when I was a doctor and
interacted with a patient one at a time
I cared so deeply that that patient
would have a good experience and when I
left the general practice of medicine
and moved as a leader my hope is that
many more patients and many more people
will have a chance to have the kind of
life I hope for them and that's the
really talented people I get to work
with are inspired and have that passion
and even drive to create those things
and that I helped well thank you so much
for your insights in your candor and we
can't wait to see how you continue to
improve the world so thank you so much
you